dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
それでも今から過労家礼儀をいくつか紹介したいと思うこれらを活用すればカラオケ
よく行く人だと思われるだろう
1番カラオケ行くというときは普通の声ではなく必ずうざったい感じでいうこと
じゃあから大きく花の質疑はから ok
から大きい組んだがカラオケ2番カラオケ施設に付いたらさらに大きな対応を取ること
じゃあお先にビールヨロシクで健3番周りの人を無視して一気に曲を3つ以上追加する
ことを p とデンモクお友達に回してからそれをもう1回奪い取ること一人の夜だ
この雪だろう
うん
i どうぞ
もう1回跳弾4番飲み物が来たらそれをこぼして友だちのせいにすることがかかる
ビールビール
何やってんだパケ死は5番外国人限定
歌が上手と世辞を言われたときそれを本気で受け止めること
まあありがとう翼 j ずむらーずにいてるって言われるんだよねボーナス日本人が
歌っているみたいと言われたらその発言を日本語能力があると勝手に解釈することだぐ
ちっちゃい時は v
1よく見てました6番サラリーマン件で日常の絶望を打ち消そうとしてネクタイを頭に
結んでソファに上がって歌う稼働
カーン
レン君なぁ橋暴動の巣歌い終わったら同僚のつまりに座り
先日の出来事を読めること楽しいなぁ
先日終わる刀健ならば歌を楽しみしかない人の番が来たら聞かずに10%へとし始める
こと君急にあ
フューチャーズあいんぐれーんじょ
柚須型エネクスいいか千葉声が枯れ始めた頃
歌えるわけがない曲をどんどん追加することまあまあ
うーんちょっと待っパターンミーター
9番マイクに唾を吐くことそれスキップしようか好き
違うスキップじゃなくてパスパスするか10番お会計を済ますときはお金がないと言っ
て払わないこと
五明で千円札しかなくてお願いしていた消しや一人1300円だから千円札でいいや
今度コーヒー買ってやるからやコーヒーてせいぜい母我々11万本当に歌うのが好き
だったら今言ったことを全て無視して一人でカラオケに行くこと
ん
me